Maalik why is he showing his body like
that that annoys the [ __ ] out of me
smooth body got a nice respect him
better molecules sweating letter here's
a boxing that's a good body right there
Bo it's good mid sectional well smooth
he's got a thin midsection little smooth
hey hey handsome dude though I know but
why he sent me a picture of him hey bro
okay better what the [ __ ] hold on this
guy sent me Moloch sent me this this
picture hold on he sent me he goes he
sent me a picture of his back there you
guys are
of his back there's a very handsome
gentleman yeah yes felt like you was
having a bad morning so here's a picture
of my back in a garden for motivation
purposes looks world to be with maja
Jeff Garlin loves Moloch too because
Jeff Jeff transmog I mean I like trains
everything and opens for him sometimes
you don't seem too thrilled there yeah
marks great when my favorite people on
earth right now I got crush on him
Moloch ever crush now here's the thing
Papa yeah if we're looking at legs you
probably the biggest calves I'm second
maltose last he's dead laughs Moloch has
Moloch has very thin leg him in John
Jones is John Jones let's got John Jones
likes Moloch you know this I know you're
listening you have John Jones like he's
got ya and he does a great joke about it
oh oh the best it's funny oh the best
joke have you heard talk about it yes
[ __ ] now Moloch you have John Jones
likes yeah that's right he does and I
know you don't watch anyway but look up
John Jones likes ya as you listen to
this look up John Jones right that's
right
yeah I got it I got to give him some
[ __ ] for posing with a shirt off can't
have that I would do the same thing he's
a young dude man Oh what the [ __ ] is
with that that's a good body right there
that's the better body that pictures he
doesn't he never lifted weights cuz he
was boxing and now he started lifting
weights and he puts on muscle quick I'm
like gentlemen yeah yeah we're Moloch
fans all right now um dude you should
suck him off in Arizona I don't like
that in the pool nope I'm straight hey
what the [ __ ] was that go back to you
no no look at the quote love is the only
force that will put aren t go to rest so
much love to you all bra Marla hey how
dare you he's like through a tree my
favorite thing is one of his homeboys
like yeah alright let me let me try to
get the right picture I hope you answers
you don't hit your pillow boys oh yeah
it's great
[Music]
hey your service [ __ ] hey Moloch you
can't see this is a nightmare
there you go we'll get back down Papa so
June 16th what day is that chin look at
the 16th I just called you researchers
no Bryan we'll be back good yeah oh hey
Molly we're on the podcast right now
look at the cuz you're you're like
looking all seductive the behind foliage
it's plainly [ __ ] to me which one of
your boys took the picture behind the
plant we got a share a room we got a
share a house in Arizona so I need some
like the back of an R&B album who I am
thank you thank you
notice best that picture got the most
likes and women love seductive looks
that's women and love only for worse
that will help what you know you go to
rest so much love to you all bruh what
wise bra that'd be awesome so much love
ladies cuz I had to keep
like Street Street or gay why the [ __ ]
did you send me a picture of your back
for quote unquote motivational purposes
this morning that was [ __ ] up your
back is not about for not about peace
bro I like it we don't know you're not
making a difference with a goddamn
picture of your back how would you
describe your back that [ __ ] you said
your back is an authority figure
ami that's so Aaron a molecule I shoes
keep the fire on the wall ik you need to
post that you need a post sensei I'm
coming Phoenix that should that should
be your your headshot yeah that's what I
do
no don't do it
that makes me super angry don't close
the picture back and say the road to
Phoenix starts here
no nobody said that either man this is
ours this whole thing is trying to have
to be a disaster we I gotta get back to
podcast we love you later handsome
bastards handsome right cat he's
good-looking he's very handsome when I
post that video I had a bunch of girls
be like who's that he cute yeah good
dude
not only has 500 likes that's okay
I'll get that hilarious there you go
to be fair he has a lot of heart i
emojis under his photos though a lot of
[ __ ] oh the girls like a lot of girls
do yeah the girls like a lot of thirsty
hoes right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch
your tongue
Oh what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]